Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
You’re in for a real treat today, because
today we’re not going to simulate just plain
regular fluids.
No!
We’re going to simulate ferrofluids!
These are fluids that have magnetic properties
and respond to an external magnetic field
and you will see in a moment that they are
able to even climb things.
You see in the reference footage here that
this also means if there is no magnetic field,
we have a regular fluid simulation.
Nothing too crazy here.
In this real-world footage, we have a tray
of ferrofluid up in the air, and we have a
magnet below it, so as the tray descends down
and gets closer to the magnet, this happens.
But the strength of the magnetic field is
not the only factor that a simulation needs
to take into account.
Here’s another real experiment that shows
that the orientation of the magnet also makes
a great deal of difference to the distortions
of the fluid surface.
And now, let’s have a look at some simulations!
This simulation reproduces the rotating magnet
experiment that you’ve seen a second ago.
It works great, what is even more, if we are
in a simulation, we can finally do things
that would be either expensive, or impossible
in the real life, so let’s do exactly that!
You see a steel sphere attracting the ferrofluid
here, and, now, the strength of the magnet
within is decreased, giving us the impression
that we can bend this fluid to our will!
How cool is that?
In the simulation, we can also experiment
with arbitrarily-shaped magnets.
And here is the legendary real experiment
where with magnetism, we can make a ferrofluid
climb up on this steel helix.
Look at that.
When I’ve first seen this video and started
reading the paper, I was just giggling like
a little girl.
So good.
Just imagine how hard it is to do something
where have footage from the real world that
keeps judging our simulation results, and
we are only done when there is a near-exact
match, such as the one you see here.
Huge congratulations to the authors.
You see here how the simulation output depends
on the number of iterations.
More iterations means that we redo the calculations
over and over again, and get results closer
to what would happen in real life at the cost
of more computation time.
However, as you see, we can get close to the
real solution with even 1 iteration, which
is remarkable.
In my own fluid simulation experiments, when
I tried to solve the pressure field, using
1 to 4 iterations gave me a result that’s
not only inaccurate, but singular, which blows
up the simulation.
Look at this.
On this axis, you can see how the fluid disturbances
get more pronounced as a response to a stronger
magnetic field.
And in this direction, you see how the effect
of surface tension smooths out these shapes.
What a visualization!
The information density in this example is
just out of this world… and it is still
both informative, and beautiful.
If only I could tell you how many times I
have to remake each of the figures in my papers
in pursuit of this…I can only imagine how
long it took to finish this one.
Bravo.
And if all that’s not enough for you to
fall out of your chair, get this.
It is about Libo Huang, the first author of
this paper.
I became quite curious about his other works,
and have found exactly zero of them.
This was his first paper.
My goodness.
And of course, it takes a team to create such
a work, so congratulations to all three authors,
this is one heck of a paper.
Check it out in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!